one
all right we're going to break into that
report to go live to the brimstone air
base in germany where politicians and
military experts from up to 40 countries
are meeting to discuss the next steps
for ukraine among them the u.s defense
secretary lloyd austin who's speaking
let's listen in uh
to set us up for
what i believe will be a very very uh
good session today
so thank you all for rallying so quickly
for this historic meeting of
the ukraine defense consultated through
it is an extraordinary gathering with
more than 40 countries represented here
today
and we're here to help ukraine win the
fight against russia's unjust invasion
and to build up ukraine's defenses for
tomorrow's challenges
as you know i came here after traveling
to heave
with my friend secretary of state
lincoln
we had a warm intended
and productive discussion with president
zielinski and his team
about the support that we're providing
the capabilities that ukraine needs
and ukraine's changing requirements as
the battle shifts
to the nonboss into the south
that visit only underscored my sense of
urgency
an urgency that i know that we all share
so i like this whole group today to
leave with a common
and transparent understanding of
ukraine's
near-term security requirements
because we're going to keep moving
heaven and earth
so that we can meet them
and as you'll hear from general walters
the coordination mechanism that we have
in place
can become even stronger
with all of your help
and we can do more through our defense
industrial bases to
continue to help ukraine defend itself
even more capably
now we're joined today by
my dear friend
ukrainian minister of defense reznikov
so it's an honor to have you here
and
we welcome your team as well
we're all here because of ukraine's
courage
because of the innocent civilians who
have been killed and because of the
suffering
that your people still endure
your country has been ravaged
your hospitals have been bombed
your citizens have been executed
your children have been traumatized
but ukraine has done a magnificent job
defending its sovereignty against
russia's unprovoked invasion
and ukraine valor and skill will go down
in military history
you know the battle of iwo jima took 36
days
the battle of the bulge lasted 40 days
and ukraine has now beaten back the
russian military for 62 days
and so
your resistance has bought brought
inspiration to the free world
an even greater resolve to nato
in glory to ukraine
we've provided our assistance at record
speed
and the whole world can see the
difference that's making on the
battlefield
you know putin never imagined that the
world would rally behind ukraine so
swiftly
and surely
and after ukraine's defeat at the battle
of heave
pardon me after russia's defeat
at the battle of eve
big distinction there mr minister
the war is now entering a new face
but nobody is fooled by putin's pretext
or by his phony claims on the dominos
so let's be clear
russia's invasion is indefensible
and so are russian atrocities
we all start today from a position of
moral clarity
russia is waiving a war of choice
to indulge the ambitions of one man
ukraine is fighting a war of necessity
and so are russian atrocities
we all start today from a position of
moral clarity
russia is waging a war of choice
to indulge the ambitions of one man
ukraine is fighting a war of necessity
to defend its democracy
its sovereignty and its citizens
but the stakes reach beyond ukraine and
even beyond europe
russia's invasion is baseless
reckless and lawless
it is an affront to the rules-based
international order
it is a challenge to free people
everywhere
and as we see this morning
nations of goodwill from around the
world stand united in our resolve to
support ukraine
in its fight against russia's imperial
aggression
and that's the way it should be
this gathering reflects the galvanized
world
says russia's invasion on february 24th
more than 30 of our allies and partners
from across the globe have joined the
united states
to rush security assistance to ukraine
and together we have committed more than
5 billion of equipment to support
ukraine's self-defense
and that includes some 3.7 billion
dollars that president biden has
committed to help ukraine
since russia russia's invasion began
my trip to kiev
my admiration for the way that the
ukrainian armed forces are deploying
these capabilities
ukraine clearly believes that it can win
and so does everyone here
now to inform our common understanding
of the situation
you'll be hearing later from several
several of my teammates including
our chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff general milley
and i look forward to hearing from all
of you as well
i know that we're all determined to do
everything we can to meet ukraine's
needs
as the fight evolves
and that includes
talking today about a framework for for
continuing to work together and look
ahead
we have much more to do
ukraine needs our help to win today
and they will still need our help when
the war is over
as president biden says our security
assistance has gone directly to the
front lines of freedom
and to the fearless and skilled
ukrainian fighters
who are standing in the breach
my ukrainian friends
we know the burden that you all carry
and we know
and you should know
that all of us have your back
and that's why we're here today
to strengthen the arsenal
of ukrainian democracy
i'm proud to be here with all of you
and i look forward
to our vital discussions
and so we'll pause for a minute and
allow our uh colleagues in the media to
depart and then we'll continue thank you
very much
all right that was u.s defense secretary
lloyd austin there speaking at the
ramstein air base in germany politicians
and military experts from up to 40
countries meeting there to discuss the
next steps to uh for rather uh ukraine
also at the ramstein air base is al
jazeera's step varsity step what's this
meeting all about
yeah uh austin has called it historical
and it is indeed very unusual to have an
international meeting at the us largest
air base with outside of the united
states it definitely gives a sign a sign
to europe that it should step up its
support according to the us to ukraine
as you say more than 40 nations are
invited it's not only nato nations all
the defense ministries ministers from
nato are here but also beyond that
there are
countries in asia countries in the
middle east and in from africa are
invited and what is also significant
here is that it's at the ramstein air
base in germany and germany has been
criticized for not doing enough uh not
sending weapons not sending heavy
weapons most particularly to ukraine and
it's interesting also to know that
germany seems to have to make have made
this turnaround just ahead of this very
important meeting by saying that they're
now gonna send uh jeopard uh g-part
tanks to ukraine it's different than
ukraine had asked for initially and
until last week until yesterday even
germany was saying they were not going
to send these tanks to ukraine they were
worried that germany would be involved
in a war with russia which they
definitely wanted to prevent also the
german chancellor has warned for this
third world war he was worried about
nuclear weapons being used but now
germany under pressure from the united
states has confirmed that they're going
to send these heavy weapons as well
which is quite significant but it will
be also talks about longer-term security
support for ukraine not only immediate
but also for the long term what is nato
and all these countries this broad
coalition
for the defense of ukraine gonna do to
help ukraine to have these security
guarantees that's all on the table
resnikoff the defense minister of
ukraine is here as austin has said but
also uh nato's chief jan stoltenberg is
here they will all speak later on and we
will hear from them in a couple of hours
all right step for the moment many
thanks to dr zero step faster live at
the ramstein air base in germany